♪ ♪
>> Jesse: WELCOME BACK.
THE MEDIA IS GETTING MORE AND
MORE RIDICULOUS WITH THEIR
ANTI-TRUMP HATRED.
LISTEN TO THIS ONE MSNBC HOST TO
DROP ALL PRETENSE OF OBJECTIVITY
AND GIVE JOE BIDEN ADVICE ON HOW
TO COUNTER THE PRESIDENT DURING
THIS CRISIS.
>> DO THEY NEED TO DO IT IN A
BIGGER WAY?
WHAT DID YOU JUST CALL IT?
THE PRESIDENT’S DAILY CLOWN
SHOW, THAT’S HIS PRESS BRIEFING.
SHOULD JOE BIDEN BE COUNTER
PROGRAMMING THAT?
SHOULD HE BE CREATING HIS OWN
CHATTER GOVERNMENT, SHADOW
CABINET, SHADOW S.W.A.T. TEAM
AND GETTING THERE AT A PODIUM
EVERY NIGHT
AND SAYING, HERE IS A CRISIS,
HERE IS WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
ADDRESS THIS?
>> Jesse: HERE IS SLEEPY JOE’S
LATEST ATTACK ON TRUMP’S
LEADERSHIP.
BECAUSE THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
FRIGHTENED AND ARE LOOKING FOR
LEADERSHIP.
WHAT BOTHERS ME IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
DOES NOT TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES ACTS LIKE THIS IS
NOT -- NOTHING IS HIS FAULT.
NOTHING IS HIS RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Jesse: DANA, I’M NOT REALLY
SURE WHO THAT WAS ON MSNBC.
I DON’T THINK SHE WAS A
PRIME TIME HOST, BECAUSE I HAVE
NEVER SEEN HER IN PRIME TIME
BEFORE, SO SHE SHOULD NOT BE
GIVEN THAT MUCH OF AN OPINION, I
GUESS SHE IS DURING THE DAY OR
SOMETHING.
THAT SEEMS A LITTLE
OUT-OF-BOUNDS IN MY OPINION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Dana: JESSE!
REGARDLESS OF WHAT OUR SHE IS
ON, IT IS SUCH A BAD IDEA.
IT IS SUCH A BAD IDEA.
IT’S SO TERRIBLE.
WE JUST SPENT A WEEK AND A HALF
TALKING ABOUT HOW THERE IS
CONFUSION ABOUT WHETHER THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR THE
GOVERNORS ARE GOING TO REOPEN
THE ECONOMY.
AND NOW WE ALL AGREE, OKAY,
THERE IS COLLABORATION AND THE
GOVERNORS HELP MAKE DECISIONS
BASED ON GUIDELINES FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT JOE BIDEN IS
IN A BIND.
THAT’S BAD.
BUT WHAT SHE IS SUGGESTING, ONE,
IT IS A TERRIBLE IDEA IF YOU ARE
A PATRIOTIC AMERICAN, BECAUSE IT
CANNOT HAVE TWO PRESIDENTS AT
THE SAME TIME.
YOU HAVE ONE PRESIDENT AT A
TIME.
I’M SORRY THAT THEY ARE IN THIS
PREDICAMENT WHERE THEY HAD TO
CAMPAIGN DURING A PANDEMIC, BUT
THAT’S THE SITUATION THEY ARE
IN.
THIS IS LIKE WHAT I USED TO DO
WITH MY SISTER WHEN I GOT HOME
FROM SCHOOL AFTER I HAD AN
AFTER-SCHOOL SNACK.
I WOULD MAKE HER PLAY SCHOOL
WITH ME.
AND THIS IS LIKE PLAYING
GOVERNMENT.
YOU DON’T TO DO THIS.
IT’S LIKE MAKE-BELIEVE.
AND I THINK IT MAKES TERRIBLE,
TERRIBLE FLOODING FOR JOE BIDEN.
>> Jesse: YOU PLAYED SCHOOL
AND GREG GUTFELD PROBABLY PLAYED
DOCTOR.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, GREG?
>> Greg: I THINK I SAW THAT
JOKE COMING LIKE A FRISBEE IN
THE DESERT.
10 MILES AWAY.
WHAT I FIND INTERESTING IS THAT
JOE IS IN THE SHADOWS.
THAT’S WHAT IS SO FUNNY ABOUT
THE COMMENTARY.
HERE’S THE THING.
NOBODY, JOE, NANCY, CHUCK, LIZ,
AOC, NOBODY CAN ANSWER THE
QUESTION, WHAT WOULD YOU DO
DIFFERENTLY THAN DONALD TRUMP?
WHAT WOULD YOU DO WHEN?
WHEN WOULD YOU START THE
ECONOMY?
HOW WOULD YOU DO IT?
THEY DON’T, THEY CAN’T SAY IT.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
A 50% CHANCE OF BEING WRONG.
SO THEY ARE PETRIFIED OF
ACTUALLY RAISING THEIR HAND AND
GOING, OH, I HAVE AN IDEA.
LET’S DO IT NOW.
SO THEY ARE NOT GOING TO STEP
FORWARD.
WHAT THEY WILL DO IS WAIT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO FLIP THE
SWITCH, OR THE DIMMER, AND ANY
COLLATERAL DAMAGE THAT THERE IS,
THEN THEY WILL LEAP FORWARD AND
THEY WILL GO HALF, WE WOULD NOT
HAVE DONE THAT.
NO SURGERY, WE WOULD NOT HAVE
DONE THAT.
YOU DID THAT TOO LATE OR YOU DID
NOT DO ENOUGH.
OR YOU ARE AN AUTO CRACKED, OR
YOU DID NOT TAKE CONTROL, BUT
THEY WILL NOT TELL YOU WHEN THEY
ARE GOING TO START OR HOW THEY
ARE GOING TO START, BECAUSE THEY
ARE TOO SCARED OF BEING WRONG.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE RIGHT,
BECAUSE BIDEN STUCK HIS NECK OUT
EARLY ON THE TRAVEL BAN, AND HE
WAS DEAD WRONG.
JUAN, GRADE JOE BIDEN’S I GUESS
PERFORMANCE IN THIS QUARANTINE
CAMPAIGN?
WOULD YOU GIVE HIM AN AA, OF B,
C?
AND WHY WOULD YOU GIVE HIM THAT
GRADE?
>> Juan: I THINK IN BIDEN’S
CASE, IT’S A MATTER OF GETTING
IN PUBLIC AND NOT ALLOWING THE
VIRUS, WHICH HAS CHANGED.
THE WHOLE CAMPAIGN LANDSCAPE
DEFINITELY FOR EVERYBODY ON
EITHER SIDE HERE, NOT ALLOWING
HIMSELF TO BE PUSHED OUT OF ANY
SPOTLIGHT BECAUSE HE IS NOT
CAMPAIGNING.
SO WHAT YOU GET IS, HE IS NOW ON
TV MORE THAN EVER, AND OF
COURSE, HE IS DOING THOSE
LIVE STREAMS FROM HIS BASEMENT
IN DELAWARE SOMEWHERE.
HE HAS BEEN ON A LOT OF TV.
AND AS I MENTIONED, THE
STREAMING EFFORTS THAT ARE GOING
OUT HAS GOTTEN MUCH BETTER IN
TERMS OF THE GRADE, I WOULD SAY
INITIALLY NOT SO GOOD, NOW
PRETTY GOOD.
BUT HE IS UP AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO HAS A DAILY
PRESS BRIEFING THAT AS THE
PRESIDENT LIKES TO SAY, ON PAR
WITH "BACHELOR" FINALE AND
MONDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL.
TO ANSWER THIS QUESTION, YOU
HAVE I THINK EVERYONE I HAVE MET
WHO HAS RUN FOR PRESIDENT THINKS
THAT THEY ARE ABOUT TO WIN.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO WIN IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT, YOU BETTER HAVE A
PLAN.
AND I DON’T THINK THERE IS ANY
REASON THAT HE SHOULD NOT BE
SAYING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
HERE IS HOW I WOULD BE DEALING
WITH IT.
AND I THINK THAT HE HAS BEEN
PRETTY CLEAR, AND I THINK OTHERS
HAVE SAID SO AS WELL, WE NEED TO
DO A BETTER JOB WHEN IT COMES TO
TESTING IN THIS COUNTRY,
PROVIDING SUPPLIES TO OUR
MEDICAL WORKERS, MAKING SURE
THAT YOU KNOW, THE BANK, THE
COMPUTERS DON’T GET ALL SCREWED
UP WHEN WE TRY TO DELIVER
STIMULUS CHECKS TO OUR WORKERS.
THESE ARE LEGITIMATE CRITICISMS
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION, AND HE
HAS TO BE ABLE TO SAY, I WOULD
DO A BETTER JOB.
>> Jesse: MAYBE HE CAN ASK LIZ
WARREN TO HAVE A LITTLE HELP
WITH THE PLAN.
SHE NOW WANTS TO BE HIS VP.
>> Katie: THAT IS TRUE, BUT DO
WE REALLY THINK THAT JOE BIDEN
IS CAPABLE OF RUNNING A SHADOW
GOVERNMENT, HE CAN HARDLY RUN
HIS OWN INTERVIEWS WHEN HE IS
GETTING --
HE CAN HARDLY FIGURE OUT WHAT
DAY IT IS AT THIS POINT.
THERE’S NO WAY HE COULD RUN A
SHADOW GOVERNMENT, I’M SURE THAT
THE COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA
WOULD LOVE FOR JOE BIDEN TO
START DOING SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
CONSIDERING HE HAS BEEN LAX ON
CHAN DAM IN CHINA, SYMPATHETIC,
HIS SON HAS BUSINESS TIES TO
CHINA, WHICH MAY STILL BE THERE,
HE WAS AGAINST THE TRAVEL BAN
AND ALLOWING PEOPLE TO GO IN AND
THE COUNTRY WHILE THE VIRUS WAS
SPREADING.
I’M SURE THAT TODAY WOULD LOVE
FOR HIM TO CONTINUE THE WORK OF
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
COVERING FOR CHINA ON THIS ISSUE
ISSUE.